if you're watching this video right now
the title is likely 100
accurate and if it's not then that's
that's on you that's
that's not only look i really tried to
build the code like in tom scott's video
you made a bot update the video every 20
seconds so that it matches the view
count pretty smart right i started
coding last night and then i ordered a
papa john's pizza i got super sleepy and
i didn't have time to finish so but this
isn't on me okay this isn't on me either
you're here too early or too late and no
amount of regret or second guessing will
ever change the fact that when the
moment needed you you weren't enough the
code just didn't work and i'm not about
to change the title every 20 [ __ ]
seconds okay i don't know how to do that
so for one of you yes it's very accurate
again this isn't a me problem like my
shoplifting this is a you problem now go
to the comments and write wow so
accurate and then blame yourself for
missing out on what would have been an
otherwise insanely cool video but you
just happen to be too early or too late
this really this this should be a lesson
to you all
do better